e to the pi i equals negative 1
is one of the most famous equations in
math, but it's also one of the most
confusing.
Those watching this video likely fall
into one of three categories
1) you know what each term means, but the statement as a whole seems nonsensical,
2) you were lucky enough to see what this
means and some long formulae explaining why it
works in a calculus class,
but it still feels like black magic, or
3) it's not entirely clear with the
terms themselves are.
Those in this last category might be in the best position to understand the explanation
I'm about to give
since it doesn't require any calculus or
advanced math, but will instead require an
open-minded to reframing how we think about numbers.
Once we do this, it will become clear
what the question means,
why it's true and most importantly why it
makes intuitive sense.
First let's get one thing straight,
what we we write as e to the x is not repeated multiplication
that would only make sense when x is a
number that we can count 1, 2, 3 and so on,
and even then you'd have to define the
number the number e first.  To understand what this
function actually does,
we first need to learn how to think
about numbers as actions.
We are first taught to think about numbers
as counting things, and addition and
multiplication are thought of with respect
counting.
However is more thinking becomes tricky
when we talk about fractional amounts,
very tricky when we talk about
irrational amounts, and downright nonsensical
when we introduce things like the square
root of -1.
Instead we should think of each number as
simultaneously being three things
a point on an infinitely extending line,
an action which slides that line along itself,
in which case we call it an "adder", and an action which stretches the line
in which case we call it a "multiplier".
When you think about numbers as adders,
you could imagine adding it with all
numbers as points on the line
all at once.  But instead, forget that
you already know anything about addition
so that we can reframe how you think
about it.
Thing of adders purely as sliding the line
with the following rule:
You slide until the point corresponding
to zero ends up where the point corresponding
with the adder itself started
When you successively applied two adders, the effect will be the same as just applying some other adder.
This is how we define their sum.  Likewise,
forget the you already know anything
about multiplication, and think of a
multiplier purely as a way to stretch
the line.
Now the rule is to fix zero in place,
and bring the point corresponding with
one, to where the point corresponding with the multiplier itself started off,
keeping everything evenly spaced as you
do so.  Just as with adders
we can now redefine multiplication
as the successive application
of two different actions.  The life's ambition of e to the x
is to transform adders into multipliers, and to do so is naturally as possible.
For instance, if you take two adders,
successfully apply them,
then pump the resulting sum through the
function, it is the same as first putting
each adder through the function separately,
then successively applying the two multipliers you get.  More succinctly,
e to the x plus y equals e to the
x time e to the y.
If e to the x was thought it as
repeated multiplication, this property
would be a consequence.
but really it goes the other way around. You should think this property is defining
e to the x, and the fact that the
special case and counting numbers has
anything to do with repeated
multiplication
is a consequence the property.
Multiple functions satisfy this property,
but when you try to define one explicitly,
one stands out as being the most natural,
and we express it with this infinite sum. By the way,
the number e is just to find to be the
value of this function at one.
The numbers is not nearly as special as the function as a whole, and the convention to
write this function as e to the x
is a vestige of its relationship with
repeated multiplication.
The other less natural function
satisfying this property
are the exponentials with different
bases.  Now the expression "e to the pi i"
at least seems to have some meaning,
but you shouldn't think about this infinite sum when trying to make sense of it.
You only need to think about turning adders into multipliers. You see,
we can also play this game a sliding and
stretching in the 2d plane,
and this is what complex numbers are.
Each numbers simultaneously a point on
the plane
an adder, which slides the plane so
that the point for 0
lands on the point for the number, and
multiplayer which fixes zero in place
and brings the point for one to the
point for the number while keeping
everything evenly spaced.
This can now include rotating along with
some stretching and shrinking.
All the actions of the real numbers still apply, sliding side to side and stretching,
but now we have a whole host of new
actions.
For instance, take this point here. We call
it "i".  As an adder,
it slides the plane up, and as a multiplier, it turns it a quarter of the way around
Since multiplying it by itself gives -1,
which is to say
applying this action twice is the same as
the action of -1
as a multiplier,
it is the square root of -1.  All adding is
some combination of sliding sideways
and sliding up or down, and all
multiplication is some combination of
stretching and rotating.
Since we already know that e to the
x turns slide side to side into stretches,
the most natural thing you might expect
his for to turn this new dimension of adders,
slides up and down, directly into the new
dimension of multipliers,
rotations.  In terms points on the
plane, this would mean e to the x takes
points on this vertical line
which correspond to adders that slide the
plane up and down, and puts them on the
circle with radius one
which corresponds with the multipliers
that rotate the plane.  The most natural way
you could imagine doing this
is to wrap the line around the circle
without stretching your squishing it
which would mean it takes a length of
two pi to go completely around the circle,
since by definition this is the ratio the
circumference of a circle to its radius.
This means going up pi would translate to
going exactly half way around the circle.
When in doubt, if there's a natural way
to do things,
this is exactly what e to the x will
do, and this case is no exception.
If you want to see a full justification for
why e to the x behaves this way,
see this additional video here.  So there
you have it,
this function e to the x take the adder pi i to the multiplayer -1.